recently i saw a quote
and the quote was this it said that
leaders are often dealers in hope
i thought that was really profound
because we talk about motivation we talk
about encouragement we talk about
management but to be a dealer and hope
i thought was particularly applicable to
what i've been speaking to a couple ceos
recently
at the beginning of each quarter
everyone has their numbers in line
the number they want to beat the number
they want to make the number they want
to achieve for the first time they have
sales goals expense goals revenue goals
number of houses i'm going to sell
multiple quantitative goals
that's the analytical side of our minds
but being
also a dealer in hope to bring balance
to your team
to be able to motivate and bring hope
that you can achieve new goals
was critical particularly for those that
were managing teams under them
to be able to talk about the numbers on
one hand and the passion and the hope
that says that you can do it especially
if you're doing it for the first time
or you're managing and mentoring someone
who has never done it before
and i thought that was particularly
profound leaders are dealers and hope
getting the heart and the motivation
behind the attainment of the numbers
it's simple but a very strong blended
message for you
to take into your monthly goal setting